tout les systèmes de sécurité
des six réacteurs
du site n'ont pas été affectés aucun
du tout
il n'y a pas eu de rejet de matières de
matières radioactives
il ya un système de suivi de la
radiation qui permet de mesurer la
radiation la radioactivité tout cela
fonctionne bien également
cependant comme vous l'imaginez
l'opérateur et le régulateur
nous disent que la situation
continue à être très intense et
dangereuse à cause des circonstances
on retrouve tout de suite benjamin
autres couvertures maître de recherche à
la fondation pour la recherche
stratégique spécialiste des questions
nucléaires militaires et civils bonjour
à vladimir poutine continue l escalade
quels sont les risques en cas de
bombardement ou d'attac des centrales
nucléaires en ukraine
attendez je pense qu'il faut quand même
commencer par
repréciser ce qui s'est passé ce matin
le plus important c'est effectivement
d'avoir pu entendre raphaël aussi qui
donnait une conférence de presse à 10h30
dont vous avez fait mention et on a
entendu quelques extraits pour le moment
eu ce que l'on sait c'est que un
projectile venant des forces russes
a atteint un bâtiment de formation ce
bâtiment formation il est un petit peu
en amont une dizaine de mètres d'une
ligne des 6 réacteurs qui sont en ligne
dans la centrale le feu est éteint il ne
peut pas
préciser leurs règles le directeur
général ne peut pas préciser de quel
type de munitions il s'agit précisément
parce qu'on ne peut pas envoyer des
équipes de criminalistique nucléaire ni
au client final 6 sur place ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que cette centrale de
sabrina est équipé de réacteurs
d'origine russe du reste de r 1000
c'est une conception moderne dans les
années 80 puis dans les années 90 avec
une enceinte de confinement qui a été
prévu pourrait prendre béton renforcé
d'acier et cette enceinte est réputé
pouvoir résister à l'impact d'un certain
nombre de munitions et y compris un
certain nombre de missiles et encore une
fois on ne sait pas quelle est la
munition qui a atteint 62 centres de
formation à quelques dizaines de mètres
on sait aussi que la radioactivité peut
être contenue dans cette centrale et
dans ces six réacteurs dont je rappelle
que 1,2 seulement est en activité en ce
moment c'est à dire à peu près 60% des
capacités d'aidé de l'ensemble des
unités d'être contenue en cas de rupture
du réacteur pour le moment on n'y est
pas là on n'en est pas là question qui
se pose c'est si la tacc et délibérée et
si effectivement l'ensemble du parc des
carnets react quels sont les risques
pour l'être être peut-être un risque de
cibles m'a écouté une réflexion de bon
sens consiste d'abord à penser qu'une
attaque délibérée pour détruire des
réacteurs n'a absolument aucun sens
comme objectif tactique il s'agit d'un
risque beaucoup trop grand que ferait
courir les militaires russes sur leurs
propres hommes sur leur propre
territoire puisque le et des centrales
sont relativement proches du territoire
russe par conséquent il s'agit ce matin
à l'évidence d'un dommage collatéral
dans une action qui visait à prendre le
contrôle du site et le site cela nous a
été rappelé par raphaël rossi est
effectivement sous contrôle des russes
même si les opérateurs sur place
naturellement reste l'ukrainien mais
sans être un tacticien métier si vous
voulez me semble évident que la maîtrise
des 15 des acteurs qui composent
l'ensemble du parc puissance ukrainien
et qui assure à peu près un peu plus de
la moitié de la production d'électricité
du pays peut être un objectif
raisonnable de l'opération militaire en
cours mais évidemment pas
l'orchestration mais ce qu'il est
possible néanmoins d'envisager un accord
militaire internationale pour que toutes
ses centrales nucléaires soient à l'abri
des attaques en réalité il ne s'agit pas
d'un accord militaire il pourrait s'agir
d'un accord international mais je vais
vous dire une chose cet accord
international il existe déjà c'est le
principe général qui que doivent
respecter tous les états membres de
l'agencé internationale d'énergie
atomique qui est de ne jamais attaquer
une installation civile de respecter
l'intégrité physique de l'installation
la sûreté et la sécurité des systèmes
qui doit être maintenu le maintien d'un
staff et de ressources humaines normales
la permanence de son alimentation
électrique une communication permanente
sur place et la fonctionnalité des
appareils de contrôle et de radiation
c'est au total sept principes qui sont
le coeur de fonctionnement
internationale que tous les réacteurs et
que naturellement la russie est réputé
connaître par coeur et qu'elle vient de
bafouer donc et qu'elle vient à
l'évidence de bafouer c'est ce qu'a dit
grossi les monts signifie quelque chose
or encore une fois le régime de blaise
routing vient de montrer ce matin qu'il
se fichait de ses engagements et je ne
parle pas des autres engagements
internationaux y compris la convention
d'interdiction du terrorisme nucléaire
initié par la russie en 2005 dont
possiblement ce matin la russie et avec
laquelle la russie est en contradiction
ce matin ce qui pourrait considérer être
dur est un acte criminel dont elle
pourrait devoir un jour à rendre compte
merci beaucoup benjamin autres
couvertures pour votre analyse et merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur france24 merci
à vous